let me take you on a wild ride to the
very edges of our universe
but it won't be as simple as traveling
through space because the edges that
we're talking about
aren't in space
they're in time
why is the universe that we see
a universe of the past
how far back into the universe's history
could you go
and
what would you see in the young universe
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth teleported to the edge
of the universe
the universe doesn't have the kind of
edge you might imagine
but there is a limit to how far into
outer space we can see from earth
and the part that we can see is called
the observable universe
the observable universe does have an
edge but it's not a border in space
it's a border
in time
when we look out into space we see the
stars and galaxies from the past and the
deeper into the universe we look
the farther back in time we see
so
join me on this mind-bending trip back
in time to the very beginning of the
universe
it seems pretty weird that our
telescopes look into the past but it all
has to do with how light travels
take the sun for example it's located
about 150 million kilometers from earth
and light travels at 300 000 kilometers
per second
so
if you look outside the light that you
see
was emitted from the sun eight minutes
ago
yeah the further an object is from earth
the longer it takes for its light to
reach you
and that's why when we look into space
we're looking backward in time
just how far back in time is that
observable edge
well
using the hubble space telescope we've
been able to look back 13 billion years
yeah we can see what the universe looked
like a mere 400 to 800 million years
after the big bang
but enough about telescopes
let's start
teleporting
our first stop would be 19 billion light
years away
at this point the visible universe would
be 3 billion years old
the earth wouldn't exist yet but stars
would be bursting into existence
they would be forming 20 to 30 times
faster than they are today
and there would be vast amounts of
radiation as active supermassive black
holes feasted on the surrounding matter
okay next we teleport to a visible point
27 billion light years away
the universe would be one billion years
old
here fewer starts would be forming
heavy elements would be rare at this
point in time so there would be no rocky
earth-like planets yet
galaxies would be less developed and
filled with young stars and everything
would be bathed in a hot cosmic
microwave background we'd reach the
first edge when the universe is 700 to
800 million years old
this is called the edge of transparency
at this stage the universe would be
filled with hot opaque glowing gas
only infrared telescopes can see past
the edge of transparency
the second edge we would reach is 31
billion light years away from earth and
it's called the age of reionization
the universe would be
550 million years old the gas that we
encountered before would be gone and the
universe would be mostly transparent
the most distant galaxy ever observed is
32 billion light years from earth
there the universe would only be 400
million years old
that is the farthest our telescopes can
see but there are indirect signs that
stars formed earlier
giving us a view deeper into space and
time
if we teleported to a time when the
universe was only 50 to 100 million
years old you'd see the very first stars
forming
before this the universe was dark
but if we went further back into time
you'd witness another visible edge
at the young age of 3 million years old
the universe would be bathed in
radiation so hot you could see it with
your naked eye
it would be like a red glow
and the furthest point we teleport to
would be 46 billion light years away
this would be the last and most
significant edge of the universe
the
ultra-energetic stage of the big bang
we call this an edge because
we can't see further than this point but
it's not the physical edge of the
universe
so
is there a solid edge out there that you
could peek over
no and here's why
the universe is constantly expanding but
it's not expanding into anything
it's more like the surface of a ball
if you walked along the surface of a
giant ball you'd end up where you
started but you'd never encounter a
physical edge
now what if the universe isn't a ball
what if it's more like a loop
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you